hello everyone and welcome to the very
strong Moscow international tournament
of 1936 we have a game from round 4 it's
hosting role kappa blanka vs. reaches
level a goes in now some of you may
remember capablanca started with two
draws and then he won't game number
three against the doom in the human had
that terrible queen blunder now
Capablanca faces a very strong player a
very strong show via the Grandmaster he
was well known for his fierce attacks
and the early pawn sacrifices to get
things started now some of you may know
this some of you may not know this he
was also a a world champion in
correspondence chess and often a second
to Mikhail Botvinnik as botanics style
is a bit different then he often used
the goes into train with him they played
secret matches had to prepare for his
World Chess Championship matches so
Botvinnik would get a hang of how to
defend against such styles so but will
that style work against someone of
Capablanca style we have to see the game
so capablanca opens with d4 but before
we see the game we do have a photo
challenge so best of luck to everyone
here it is who are the people in this
photo if you are unable to recognize
anyone
that's because these are the members of
the Prague chess club now I was
contacted by Bill Miller ship via email
he said that their chess club in in
Prague is some 187 members
large and but mostly they get like six
people to show up and they they get
together like once every two weeks maybe
if they had more people they would get
together more often so basically he said
if I could help him promote it a little
bit if anyone is in Prague check out the
progress club they play in the chess
cafe in the main square every two weeks
they are open to all levels so as you
can see some very nice people there you
know having a couple of beers playing
chess the boards are very nice it seems
very comfortable a lot of books there on
the shelf there's the I believe that's
the DT 2010 chess clock so they are well
equipped so
you know if you're in Prague maybe you
don't know they they have their
get-togethers you know do do you know
visit them maybe you'll have the time of
your life I will put a link to their to
their to their group on get on what's
the website get together calm or
something like that meet up.com in the
description below so you know do check
it out if you're in Prague you know
maybe it wouldn't hurt to check them out
so getting back to the game
d4 we have Knight to f6 buyer goes in c4
e6 Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 the
nimzo-indian defense Queen to b3 the
Spielman variation we have Knight to c6
defending the Bishop e3 d5 Knight to f3
castles and a3 now attacking the bishop
before reacting to this D captors on c4
attacking the Queen Bishop captures on
c4 and now Bishop back to d6
and here at our Gaussian of course would
very much enjoy playing Knight to a5
getting rid of at least one one Bishop
from capablanca so there are a couple of
ways you can avoid this you can either
move the bishop back you could move the
Queen for example to c2 Capablanca
chooses a different idea he plays Bishop
to cease Bishop to b5 threatening to
capture the knight on c6 and a ruined
black's pawn structure and eventually
win that c6 pawn and here since the cup
of monka did play twice with the same
piece in the opening so he's kind of
breaking the the opening principles so
air goes in goes precisely by by the
right principle he plays d5 as long as
King is still in the center you know you
have to open up the position so e5 we
have Bishop captures on c6 panca first
pawn captures on d4 Knight captures and
e4 and pawn captures on c6 and here
Capablanca captures the pawn Knight
captures on c6 attacking the Queen and
e8 we have Queen to d7 attacking couple
Blancas knight on c6 Knight goes back to
d4 and now Queen to g4 immediately
rushing into the attack already
threatening to capture on g2
and here you don't really have a lot of
options you could go King f1 but then
your rook will be out of the game so
kappa blanka plays the strongest move he
castles even though it seems a bit risky
the bishop is eyeing both the bishops
are eyeing the king's side there this
bishop already eyeing h2 our queen is
already on g4 the knight is here the
rooks are the rooks can easily come into
the attack but you know capablanca is
not afraid and here if you tried
something like queen h5 immediately to
go for this
then f4 would be a very strong defensive
idea for white another thing is you
might want to go c5 kind of force white
to go back to f3 then this will this
will kind of stop at the F pawn so c5
would be the best idea here but her
cousin has a different idea he plays
Bishop 286 attacks Capablanca rook but
this gives Capablanca just enough time
to consolidate and if you don't do
something quickly then you're just gonna
be a pawn down against kappa blanka
Capablanca plays h3 first and in between
move before reacting to the threat
against the rook we have Queen to h4 and
now Knight back to f3 again with an
attack against the Queen and you know
they're consolidating bringing more
pieces to defend the White King Queen to
h5 and only now rook to e1 we have rook
a to b8 attacking Kappa Blancas Queen
Queen to a4 and now Bishop to b7 so a
couple monk is still up upon but the
position is is very intense here both of
these bishops are eyeing the eyeing a
couple hungers King and he has to be
very careful first of course he he
doesn't want to allow quick Bishop
captures on f3 so he pushes efore and
not allowing it we have h6 creating some
breathing space for a king maybe in the
future but also preparing the diamond
overnight h7 to g5
we have Bishop to e3 capturing an a7 is
also possible but capablanca is already
up upon he knows that if he defends his
extra pawn will be I will prove to be
decisive and capturing here doesn't
really give a black any any great
refutation but you know there's no need
to grab more material
you need so rush up to e3 developing a
piece you should never neglect the
development rook F to e 8 and now rush
up to d 4 still ignoring the pawn and a7
we have knife to h7 error goes and
prepares to bring the knight over to the
attack and now Bishop captures an a7 na
Capablanca figures it's safe to grab the
a7 pawn we have rook to e8 and now it
seems that for the price of this pawn
come on Cass Bishop is now trapped how
do you how do you get out of this well
kappa blanka finds away and it it's
perhaps this move that error goes in
missed Queen to b5 attacking the bishop
but there's no time to react to this
because also cup of mana is attacking or
ago since Queen on h5 the only move you
have that is that is you know playable
here for black is Queen captures on b5
so we have Queen captures and Knight
character son b5 now the night is also
protecting the bishop and it's very nice
because you can't kick away the knight
the bishop will be hanging on d6
so after Knight b5 we have rook captures
and before grabbing the pawn rook
captures Bishop captures and now Knight
the d2 attacking the bishop on e4 Bishop
to d3 attacking the knight on unbe 5 and
now basically forcing Kappa Blanc at the
capture on d6 we have Knight captures we
have rook captures and now Knight back
to e for the Knights are still kind of
protecting each other but there is no
way to take advantage of this night to a
fate you do have to bring your piece
into the game nice the c5 attacking the
bishop on d3 Bishop to f5 and now comes
Knight to f3 so now a couple Blanca is
still up upon it's not that only that
he's up upon the material on the King
side is completely even but on the Queen
side he does have two points against one
and also the a pawn is a passed pawn so
a very very important difference we have
night to e6 offering a trade of knights
but first rook to c1 we have King to
effect improving the position of the
King and now Knight captures Bishop
captures and now Knight to d4
threatening to capture the bishop rook
to b7 threatening the B to pawn first
before and now Bishop to d7 now
controlling this knight on d4
we have f4 now kappa blanka is preparing
to bring his king also into the game
King to be 17 - f2 rook to e7 our
attacking the a3 pawn and now rook to c3
so notice how capablanca is you know
keeping it keeping it cool and just
controlling the position King to d6
bringing his King deeper into the
position but now Capablanca plays a
spectacular move a favorite move of the
engine plays rook to d3 and now notice
how the night the points here are
controlling c5 and E 5 the knight is
controlling c6 and ecigs the King can't
move the King can go left or right and
the knight is a threatening Knight b5 a
discovered check winning the rook on a 7
so this forces the King to go back King
to e7 and now of course this gives more
time and opportunity for kappa blanka to
improve the position of his own King
King to e3 we have looked to a for now
rope the c3 attacking the c7 point and
now rooked King to d6 defending the pawn
here top of milanka repeats the position
rook to d3 we have King to be 7 and now
rogue back to c3 Ragusan doesn't mind
repeating moves we have Kings d6 and now
a kappa blanka doesn't want a draw by
threefold repetition so he goes nice to
e2 making room for his king to enter the
position we had g6 and now rook to d3
again with a check here kappa blanka is
trying to try and not trying to but you
know allowing our goes into trick
himself with King to c6 here b5 wood of
course when the bishop on d7 as the King
has no squares to still be protecting
the bishop after b5 check but after work
today 3 he goes back King e6 and now we
have King to d4 Capablanca calmly
improves the position of his King
instead he could go for the forcing
variation f5 check now you still have to
protect the bishop here so you can't
capture with the King and after G
captures you've ruined your pawn
structure then comes a Knight to f4
check King to e7 and nice to d5 check
now you don't wanna you don't want to go
anywhere like King e6 then you allow
this with check
and after something like came to a fate
you still capture the pawn and now you
are still up upon but now instead of
just being up upon you have to pass
pawns and the Black has a doubled c-pawn
a completely winning position for white
so Capablanca doesn't go for this
I rather he calmly improves the position
King before we had rook to a6 and now
comes rope to e3 check King d6 and now
Knight to c3 we have f5 and now comes b5
attacking the rook and simply grabbing
more space
rook moves and now came to see for a
bishop to e6 check King simply moves to
be for c5 now forcing kappa blanka the
captured upon via Amazon as the King has
nowhere to go so be captures in c6 but
it doesn't help you I call that much as
he can't capture it the bishop is still
under attack so we have Bishop to g8 now
preparing to capture the pawn and kappa
blanka plays nice the b5 check forcing
goes into captured upon team captures on
c6 and now comes rock to d4 not allowing
the King to go anywhere
we have g5 now comes rock to d6 check
King moves now comes pawn captures and
g5h capture son g5 and rook to g6 now as
you can see there is no way to defend it
the g5 pawn rook to f8 and now simple
rook captures on g5 we had f4 now comes
tonight to d4 rook to c8 now comes rock
to g7 with check king b6 and now rook to
be g6 with check King b7 and now nice to
be v threatening Knight to d6 winning
the rook so rope to a fate knife to d6
with check we have a king to be 8 and
now comes h4 and it was in this position
I move 63 that which is love or a goes
in resigned at the game why did he
resign well he's down to pawns there's
really nothing to hope for here with the
black pieces a couple Blanca will simply
put his rook on g7 completely cut off
the black King and then the past h1 and
the past a pond will be decisive there's
nothing really it really you can do
about this the King can come help there
black luck has no
no playable moves here so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and it
was a very interesting how after this
King to his six move kappa blanka of
course a couple Monica knew that FY was
winning but capablanca was sometimes
like that he didn't like the force
things he knew that King default was
winning and he liked positions like this
he often said that if you have to
complicate things in chess then you do
not understand chess so a very nice idea
I mean probably a lot of you who enjoy
you know combinations everything would
immediately play this move but not Jose
broke up a bunker he went for King
before and then the position simply you
know simply told the truth the head the
position deteriorated for black and
there were there was nothing you know
every move he played it was simply a
ruining the position for him so yeah
after h4 the game was over and a very
nice win so starting with two draws and
now two wins in the very strong 1936
international tournament in Moscow we'll
check out some of the more games from
this this miniseries I do hope you're
enjoying so yeah that's it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with another
interesting video and I do hope you
enjoyed my stream as I'm actually
recording this video before the stream
but I hope everything went well with the
stream and that you all showed up and
enjoyed it so and the link to delicious
tournament for tomorrow will be in the
description below also so you know feel
free to already register for it if you
if you will be able to join us tomorrow
thank you and I'll see you soon